[Music]
all right the dak prescott contract
news emerged on monday night still not
official yet but no reason to think it
won't be four years 160 million dollars
let's talk a little bit chris about what
impact this is going to have on the team
my understanding is they are bracing for
bigger cap problems
next year right not this year and
i i i think that amari cooper
definitely will be on next year because
that five-year 100 million dollar
contract is really a two-year 40 million
dollar contract
this is year two after this year they
can walk away with
minimal cap consequence no guaranteed
money trade him
cut him and probably trade him because a
20 million
a year receiver is going to be very
difficult to trade
i think he's done after this year i
think that's the easiest takeaway for me
from the dak prescott contract the
easiest way to shed cap
dollars is to move on from cooper
because you've got
cd lamb you've got michael gallup you've
got other guys
who can play the position for a lot less
than 20 million a year no doubt
they're set up that way i think first
off i mean i think you're spot on with
the amari cooper thing i would imagine
there's a good chance that this is his
last year in the dallas cowboys
the contract it sets up the way you
explained it exactly right they can get
out of it with minimal damage
he listen he does have a little bit of
an injury history we know that
you know i mean it's always it seems to
be always something you know two years
ago there was a lot of
nagging lower leg injuries and whatever
else that was underwhelming so he's
always had to deal with that
and i think the bottom line is you know
what you're talking about
you know they're they're they are
plentiful at the wide receiver position
it's pretty special i mean you just said
those two guys okay and then you get
into
okay cedric wilson he's a hell of a
player for them
you know they got other options that
wide receiver even noah brown isn't
horrible for them i mean there's plenty
there
but you're right i i just think within
that i would see amari cooper being gone
and
you know you brought up with zeke l i
mean zeke elliott
that's another one i just i have a hard
time i would think this is the last year
for zeke elliot with the dallas
boys yeah go ahead here's here's the
problem for the cowboys
right well it's not the option it's the
it's the rolling guarantees
that become vested one year early his
salary for 2022
becomes fully guaranteed march of 2021.
that's the way you do a contract you
know a lot of these contracts
it becomes fully guaranteed march of the
year that the salary is due to be paid
so it gives the team a chance to get out
of it
well the cowboys if they get out of it
now
they still owe him this year's salary
which is actually more than next year's
salary i think this year's is actually a
little bit less but either way
his salary for this year is already
guaranteed yeah so if you cut him to
avoid next year's you still owe him this
year's
so if you keep him you owe him next
year's and this year's
and i think ideally you'd like to try to
trade him but who's going to take on two
years for about 21 million dollars
no i don't think anybody will no this is
going to be a tough decision for them
what about urban meyer
and and you know a guy who knows ezekiel
very well now he's got james robinson at
a peanuts right contract because he was
undrafted
out of illinois state would you that's a
lot you got the cap space but that's a
lot to dump
into your running back position but boy
you bring trevor lawrence to town you
got ezekiel elliott
banging the ball between the tackles
that makes life a little easier for your
quarterback
i get that but i i don't think i could
live with keeping him at that number or
trading for him with that number
i i i couldn't do that right now i mean
you know we just have the gra
the graphic that just before this on the
bottom of the screen said it's
he's got the highest cap number of all
the running backs in football this year
you know that that doesn't match up uh i
i mean mike i don't know
i mean decisions are tough they might
maybe they have to look at zeke elliott
and go
cut you or we got to restructure the
contract go ahead
see what else is out there but we'll
offer you more than anybody else mill
maybe right now
but it just can't be at this number
going forward it just it doesn't make
sense i don't know how dallas can make
it work so
that's where i i wouldn't be shocked if
we start to hear those type of rumors
here in the next few weeks
i would not want to be committed to
paying zeke
elliott big money for 2022
that would be the big issue and i i
remember that aspect of the contract
that's the thing we liked about it right
because
it kind of like it put the the cowboys
in a handcuff
you know every march to go wait we're
committing for two years down the road
here
you know what are we gonna do they do
have a decent
a pretty damn good running back behind
him i don't think it's that big of a
fall off at this point of zeke elliott's
career
and i don't like saying this just so
everybody knows because i i mean i
respect zeke elliot a whole lot
but i'm just talking business in the nfl
here and i think this could be a real
possibility here over the next few weeks
okay here here are the specific numbers
so we're all on the same page yeah cool
9.6 million dollar salary this year
fully guaranteed already right next year
12.4 million becomes fully guaranteed
later this month so they're looking at
22 million dollars fully guaranteed
to ezekiel elliott if they have him on
the roster later this month
or 9.6 if they let him go
right now or if they trade him right now
and also trading him
now would create a 14.9 million dollar
cap charge
cutting him with the post june 1
designation
has a 4.1 million dollar cap
charge trading him after june 1 4.1
million dollar cap charge they've got
some flexibility they've got some
possibilities
but their hands are tied because of that
contract that fully
vests next year 2022 salary
in march of this year he's in a great
position and all he has to do is sit
back and say hey
my contract is what it is you want to
tear it up that's fine you know you owe
me 9.6 million
for this year either way and uh if you
hold me until the end of the month
you owe me 22 million over the next two
years yeah i i i
that would be a stunner you know i've
been trying to respond that's right
the stunner where's there's going to be
i feel like there's going to be one
where we
say holy crap um and how and look think
of it from a pr
standpoint from dak's perspective if you
sign back
and you turn around and cut ezekiel
elliott doesn't that set
dak up for a lot of extra criticism
that because of you because of your
contract
your teammate got cut your friend got
cut the guy that
you came into the league remember when
they were rookies we didn't know which
guy was a rookie of the year it was one
of the other
right there was talk one or the other
was the mvp that year they had a great
rookie season of 2016.
yeah but but the the point is if they
have to turn around
and say see you later to ezekiel elliott
now to avoid the extra 12.4 million in
guaranteed salary for next year
it's going to be tough for dak he's
already got pressure on him by virtue of
the new contract if zeke is gone
and they're relegated to someone else at
tailback that's not going to be good for
anybody but that may be their only way
out of this mess especially if they're
concerned about the cap hit next year
i think that's the big thing it's about
next year that's where
i i i don't think i could swallow that
pill if i'm the dallas cowboys
i don't and you know to your point
listen there'll be a few guys in the
locker room
that'll say that okay i'm sure
but at the reality of the situation
most of the guys who really get the nfl
and how it goes they're not going to
look at it and go it's dak prescott's
fault they're gonna go
no it's zeke elliott's fault he just
hasn't played as well that's all there
is to it
you know there's just been too many runs
like we talked about over the last two
years where
there's there's too much meat left on
the bone where you go yeah okay that was
a 15-yard run
but he's the highest paid running back
in football and it was one guy that
tackled him
and i'd go yeah that 15-yard run was
good
but if we took dalvin cook or derek
henry or alvin kamara
i promised you that same run would have
been 45 yards
or 50 yards or dalvin cook might have
hit his head on the goal post like derek
henry
and that's the difference see that's
where people get a little lost in stats
sometimes and thing it's not always
about
what your stat was it's about what did
you leave on the field too that you have
to take into account and to me that's
the biggest issue with zeke right now
and i
i really don't like saying it because
he's a car crash runner
who's killed himself and plays a tough
brand of football but
unfortunately as we know it's a brutal
position and it does seem like it's
starting to go downhill in in a hurry
and if i'm dallas
i i'm i'm i'm parting ways with zeke
elliott
have you seen enough from tony pollard
that you're comfortable with him taking
over that job yeah
i have i i'm i'm i'm i mean i like what
i see i mean there's there's times where
you turn on games last year and you go
well i'm not
sure tony pollard's not better i'm not
sure he
can't take you know advantage of more of
what's there to be had at this point
yeah maybe he can't smash his head and
shoulders in there
you know which would be a three yard
gain and zeke gets five or six tony
pollyard probably only gets the three or
four yard gain
but it's the other place where i look at
when he gets on the edge or there's a
hole where i go
i'm not sure tony pollard can't take
advantage of more at this point
than zeke ellie it can and like you've
said so many times and the and
you know the cowboys got a pretty the
jones family they got a pretty good eye
for talent
to where i would think they think hey we
can get another stud running back in
here to go along with tony pollard and
if we if we part ways with zeke elliott
in hindsight though you think about 2019
yeah disastrous business year for the
dallas cowboys
they blew their chance to get dak
prescott for a hell of a lot less than
40 million a year
and they never should have paid ezekiel
i mean we in hindsight we were banging
the drum for ezekiel we supported him
through his holdout
get paid get paid from the player's
perspective
get paid for team's perspective you got
to know when to say
we're not paying that's whether it's the
rams we're not paying jared goff
and the packers are trying to work that
now with aaron jones to get back to what
we talked about last hour
right they don't want to get caught up
in the idea that aaron jones has been a
great tailback for us for four years and
he's got superstar potential
he's a big part of the team we can find
another running back we're not going to
overpay
for the running back who is currently on
our roster and the ezekiel elliott
situation
would be maybe the first thing that
brian goody-goons points to if anyone
within the organization says how can you
take this chance
because we're not going to be the team
that is strapped with a tailback
contract that we wish we hadn't entered
into
yeah i i i think so listen yeah we we
were banging the drum i mean we're pro
player that way
you're right and and at the time
you know yet the team was kind of
orchestrated around him
he had been the one to make it go you
know we were the ones just saying like
zeke now's the time to hold out
and get the money it you know it's
dallas's job to figure out the
conversation about how much money how
long the contract is and all of that
and it's on them to know wait how much
does he realistically have in the tank
do we really think he's gonna be still a
top three top four top five running back
two
three years down the road you know
that's that's where
they they made a little mistake here
there's no doubt about it but
i think rather than compound that and
with some of the issues they have on
their roster all together
that to me would be the the move and it
yeah it's going to create a splash but
i think it might be a necessary one for
the dallas cowboys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports